sie sind klein wendig und können tödlich
sein
ausgerüstet mit künstlicher Intelligenz
sind Drohnen im Schwarm vielseitig
einsetzbar und schwer zu bekämpfen es
ist wirklich eine Revolution diese Thron
haben und dass es ihre wichtigste
Neuerung auch eine Schwarmintelligenz im
Gefecht sollen drohnenschwärme Soldaten
unterstützen und entlasten die Schwärme
werden immer größer und immer Autonummer
dies alles selbst manuell durchzuführen
würde jegliche menschliche
Verarbeitungsfähigkeit über übersteigen
ausgerüstet mit Kameras zur
Gesichtserkennung und sprengensätzen
werden drohnenschwärme zu fliegenden
minibomben es kommt wie bei allen
anderen Waffensystemen drauf an ob die
menschliche Kontrolle gewährleistet ist
China ist beim Wettrüsten um die
schwarmtechnologie ganz vorne mit dabei
in diesem Video demonstriert die
chinesische Rüstungsindustrie wie ein
Schwarm intelligenter drohnenautonom
durch einen dichten Bambuswald fliegt
ohne sich in Essen zu verfangen dank
eines vorprogrammierten Algorithmus zur
Kollisionsvermeidung
auch im Bereich bewaffneter Kampfdrohnen
ist China in der Entwicklung schon einen
Schritt weiter nach der Stufe des
vogelschwarms bei dem die Drohnen
Information fliegen sind sie nun bei der
Stufe des bienenschwarms bei dem
einzelne Drohnen unterschiedliche
Aufgaben übernehmen können
die Chinesen arbeiten an einem
Bienenschwarm der auf See eingesetzt
werden soll gegen amerikanische
Flugzeugträger ja das sind also kleine
Drohnen die so ein Flugzeugträger
anfallen die könnte nicht mit einmal
versenken aber die kriechen in jeder
Öffnung zerschneiden alles manche töten
manche machen Leitungen kaputt andere
Suche nach Kraftstoff und dergleichen
mehr die werden ein paar Tage brauchen
oder vielleicht eine Woche dann haben
die den Flugzeugträger zerlegt
[Musik]
auch Deutschland forscht inzwischen an
der schwarmtechnologie Florian Seibel
entwickelt seit acht Jahren mit seiner
Firma quantum systems in Bayern
überwachungsdrohnen für den zivilen und
militärischen Einsatz die Vektor Drohne
liefert Quantum seit letztem Jahr zur
Aufklärung an die Ukraine auch die
Bundeswehr hat acht dieser Drohnen mit
Spezialkameras und infrarotsensorik für
den eigenen Bestand gekauft für sie soll
quantum systems nun im Auftrag des
Bundesverteidigungsministeriums
gemeinsam mit Airbus drohnenschwärme
entwickeln die einzelnen Drohnen
kommunizieren untereinander mit Hilfe
von künstlicher Intelligenz das mal
vielleicht die eine Drohne in einer
besseren Position ist als die andere die
einen hat vielleicht eine Spezialkamera
die die andere nicht hat so dass dieser
Schwarm im Prinzip durch die Vielzahl an
Drohnen intelligenter wird und auch
resilienter wenn ich eine verlier habe
ich noch zwei oder drei weitere auf die
zurückgreifen kann und natürlich die
Geschwindigkeit mit der wird dann auch
aufklären die wollen wir natürlich
möglich ST ähm erhöhen ja und wenn es um
die Vermisstensuche geht vielleicht auf
dem Mittelmeer zum Beispiel ähm dann
geht's natürlich darum möglichst schnell
möglichst viel Fläche aufzuklären und da
brauche ich dann eben mehrere Drohnen
schwarmtest am Flughafen
Oberpfaffenhofen per Knopfdruck steigen
drei Vektor Drohnen gleichzeitig auf
jede in der Luft mit einer eigenen
Mission
ausgestattet mit einer künstlichen
Intelligenz sind diese
aufklärungsdrohnen in der Lage Objekte
zu erkennen und eigenständig zu
analysieren die Technologie dafür
liefert das thüringische Start-ups
Spleen Lab mit seinen Experten auf dem
Gebiet maschinelles Lernen
kann ist in den Videodaten Objekte
unterschiedlicher Typen zum Beispiel
Fahrzeuge Personen also uniformierte
Personen Kinder Erwachsene diese
erkennen über die über das Video
verfolgen und dann auch entsprechend
klassifizieren das Ziel dieses
Forschungsprojektes intelligente
unbemannte drohnenschwärme für die
Bundeswehr zu entwickeln die künftig
Kampfjets begleiten und unterstützen
sollen
er wusst bringt hier als großer Player
seine Expertise auf dem Gebiet
Simulation und Schwarm Algorithmen mit
ein schließlich sollen die hier
gesammelten Erfahrungen in das Projekt
future combat Air System kurz FKS
einfließen an dem Deutschland gemeinsam
mit Frankreich und Spanien arbeitet bei
afgas geht es darum zu vernetzen
bemannte unbemannte Systeme den den
Flieger der sechsten Generation der als
bemannte System auch quasi im Zentrum
wenn man so will gedanklich fliegt aber
der von Drohnen und auch Drohnen
schwärmen begleitet wird und der auch in
ganz andere Dimensionen sich vernetzen
können muss ins Weltall zum aufs Wasser
aufs Land in alle sozusagen
Dimension die ist dies im Gefecht angeht
diese Kombination ist und die verändert
die Krieg Führung radikal jeder
thronschwamm jede einzelne Drohne gibt
ihr Wissen weiter an die nächste Drohne
an den nächsten Schwarm und das Gewissen
geht niemals verloren und ist gebunden
in einer
komplett klaut wie das bezeichnet wird
und das ist das Gehirn dieses
gefechtsverbandes der Zukunft auch
israel setzt intelligente
drohnenschwärme ein zur Aufklärung aber
auch für den Einsatz im Häuserkampf
bewaffnet und ausgerüstet mit KI zur
Gesichtserkennung
solche Kampfdrohnen erlernen komplexe
akrobatische Manöver
mit einem Ziel und Auftrag programmiert
können sie weitgehend autonom agieren
die Entscheidung zwischen Leben und Tod
fällt allerdings am Ende noch ein Mensch
also so ein drohnenschwarm braucht
blitzschnelle Entscheidungen braucht
sehr viele Informationen die von einer
KI und von Software verarbeitet werden
dazu ist der Mensch gar nicht in der
Lage das heißt wenn wir mit drinnen
schwärmen arbeiten dann wird der Mensch
aus der Entscheidung Schleife
rausgenommen und insofern besteht eben
die Gefahr dass letztendlich auch
tötungsentscheidung von der KI getroffen
werden und das sollten wir unbedingt
vermeiden kritiker warnen vor ethischen
und moralischen folgen sollte der Mensch
die Kontrolle verlieren und KI
übernehmen je größer der Schwarm desto
größer die Gefahr dass bei einem Angriff
viele Menschen verletzt oder getötet
werden
können solche Systeme überhaupt noch
zivile Ziele von militärischen Zielen
sauber unterscheiden dass die große
Frage
und man muss bedenken dass eine
künstliche Intelligenz die ja dann diese
drohnenschwärme steuert Menschen nicht
als Menschen sondern als Datenmuster
betrachtet und solche Systeme kennen zum
Beispiel auch kein Skrupel also es
oder wenn sich ein Fehler bei einer
Drohne einschleicht z.B wird der
übertragen auf den ganzen Schwarm was
verheerende Folgen haben kann das sind
alles Risiken technische Risiken
völkerrechtliche Risiken die man bis
heute nicht in den Griff bekommen hat
entscheidende Fragen die auch
europäische Rüstungsunternehmen
beschäftigen daher arbeitet Airbus beim
Projekt fkas an einer KI die Drohnen
künftig mit einem künstlichen gewissen
ausstatten soll
indem wir zusammen mit dem
Fraunhofer-Institut in den zusammen mit
mit Think Tanks indem wir zusammen mit
mit Religionswissenschaftlern und
anderen Interessierten und Ethikern
Regeln ableiten die dann sozusagen in
die Software implementiert werden können
und die die Fähigkeit von Anfang an das
mit rein zu designen ist es ist der Weg
den wir gehen und das hat der richtige
Weg man wird dann sicherlich über die
Zeit lernen wie man die Schwellen
sozusagen optimiert dass man am Ende
nicht nur der gute ist der aber jedes
Gefecht verliert was automatisiert ist
das kann auch nicht dass in der Sache
sein aber wie man eben seine
völkerrechtlichen und auch seine
ethischen Standards dabei aufrecht hält
eine weitere Herausforderung beim
Einsatz von ki-gesteuerten
drohnenschwärmen was wenn sie von
feindlichen Kräften oder Terroristen
gehackt werden was wenn sie gekämmt
werden also ihr Funk und GPS-Signal
unterbrochen oder gestört wird im
schlimmsten Fall könnte sich der
drohnenschwarm gegen einen selbst
richten die aufklärungs Drohnen von
quantumsystems sind gegen solche
Angriffe bereits gewappnet mit beliebig
viel Aufwand kann ich natürlich alles
auf der Welt irgendwann hacken aber ich
sag mal die Verschlüsselungstechnologien
der grad mit dem wir da unterwegs sind
der ist sicherlich ausreichend dass
selbst wenn man mit viel Aufwand daran
geht unsere Flugzeit
zu kurz ist als dass man da dann in drei
vier Stunden wirklich hin Zugriff auf
die Drohne bekommen könnte und das ist
natürlich auch essentiell dass wir sowas
in Europa entwickeln in Deutschland
entwickeln und da sind natürlich
chinesische Produkte absolut tabu ja und
da müssen wir natürlich auch gucken dass
wir da nicht hinten runterfallen in all
diesen Technologien und der eigene dann
auch an den Start bringen
bereits so hat die deutsche
Rüstungsfirma rein Metall mit skynex
eine Flugabwehrkanone gegen
drohnenschwärme entwickelt das System
wurde auch an die Ukraine geliefert
dort spielen im Krieg Drohnen und ihre
Abwehr eine wichtige Rolle laut Angaben
britische analisten verbraucht alleine
die Ukraine jeden Monat im Schnitt
10.000 Drohnen bei Angriffen auf
russische Stellungen auch Russland setzt
Drohnen aus dem Iran gegen ukrainische
Truppen und Infrastruktur ein ob in
diesem Krieg auch drohnenschwärme zum
Einsatz kommen ist laut Experten noch
unwahrscheinlich doch das ist so kommen
könnte ist nicht ausgeschlossen denn
jeder Krieg ist ein Testfeld neuer
Technologie
Krieg ist immer furchtbar ja und wir
wollen keinen Krieg wir wollen aber
gerüstet sein dass es zu keinem Krieg
kommt und die
Vorbereitung auf den Hyper war im
Informationszeitalter findet ohne uns
statt oder mit uns unsere Gegner werden
nicht zögern etwa so etwas zu schaffen
Russland ist im Moment noch nicht so
weit die Arbeiten aber dran ja China ist
weit vor uns und wir dort nicht mitmacht
muss ich dann eben auch gefallen lassen
dass man politisch erpressbar ist dass
man international nicht mehr mitreden
kann dass man angreifbar wird die
Entwicklung intelligenter
drohnenschwärme gewinnt militärisch
weltweit an Bedeutung Deutschland ist
nun mit dabei die ki-gesteuerten Vektor
Drohnen die Florian Seibel und sein Team
bei Quantum derzeit mit Airbus für die
Bundeswehr testen sind unbewaffnet hier
geht es um schnellere Rettung präzisere
Aufklärung und nicht zuletzt auch darum
bei dieser Technologie in Europa
aufzuholen
[Musik]